when you did Garth in Wayne's World that
too in a sense was an impression right
that was a friend of yours my brother
though that was your brother brother
Brad that's why Garth had the stun gun
because Brad's kind of he invented the
Video Toaster and he's an engineer at
STAR Labs your brother's a genius he's
very very talented I call him a genius
but Brad if we call him right now he had
master of understatement yeah I could
make a nuclear device out of a paperclip
and that was kind of the core voice for
Garth high I could do better or what in
the movie goes excuse me I'd like to get
by now and there's something very
intoxicated about that rhythm that
understated lilt were you in on the
writing about as well
Mike was writing it and I I was putting
stuff in right now but then I would see
that the stuff wasn't in anymore and so
I actually three weeks before we started
shooting I said no thanks but no thanks
I actually quit the movie Wow
oh no kidding yeah I I just I you know I
just you guys go ahead I don't want I
don't want it I'd have nothing to do in
the movie really but they can't do that
movie without you well I they they
finally they didn't believe me at first
but I'm kind of crazy I don't know I'm
not it wasn't a money issue for you it
was more of a hey yeah I'm I'm a
romantic I grew up with Peter Sellers
and the Beatles and Stanley Kubrick I
didn't think of the money in Fame I
swear to God I I just thought well I
have nothing to do in the movie so
that's cool is that part of the riff too
between you and Mike Myers or no sort of
won but but like that you were difficult
to get to the know they basically gave
me the script and I respectively you
know I was respectful I just wove in if
you're gonna spoon this view and you
know I was still being the sidekick and
respectfully just wove apart for me in
the movie right I'm sort of a narc or
whatever and then we we got along great
making the movie and the first movie has
a lot of you know so it was made quick
and easy and just turned out great